[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and we're thrilled to have you here
we're so excited about what the future
holds and we've invested a lot to make
you successful with Google Cloud so you
can build applications faster and more
secure than ever
you may have heard Thomas kurian talk
about how we offer prescriptive Guidance
with an opinionated approach to solve
developer velocity challenges in today's
session I'm going to show you how
exactly we do this by highlighting how
Google Cloud lets you deliver secure
applications in an open manner even
though working remotely has become the
norm working faster remotely and across
distributed teams continues to be a
challenge typical friction points
include onboarding Road employees
setting up Dev and test environments and
long build times just to name a few
when it comes to security code and data
exfiltration risks are key
this is especially true in sensitive and
regulative environments
customers tell us that current solutions
to secure Dev environments can add
developer friction to the experience
for example streaming-based Solutions
May introduce unwanted latency
in running your specific containers may
not be fully supported
solving developer velocity challenges
requires a two-pronged approach
how do we not only make it easier for
developers to build applications but
also easy for it admins to securely
scale in Dev environments
to address this
I'm excited to announce the availability
of cloud workstations
think of cloud workstations as providing
pre-configured but customizable
developer environments in the cloud with
your favorite dev tools pre-installed
and up to date
Cloud workstations come with multi-ide
support such as IntelliJ pycharm Ryder
sea lion code OSS and others as part of
this fully managed experience Cloud
workstations can provide security
capabilities as you code which can be
extended to other parts of your software
supply chain from build dependency
management to deployment
on the product side we are taking those
efforts to the next level with the
launch of software delivery Shield
software delivery Shield provides a
fully managed end-to-end software supply
chain security
this starts with the IDE and includes CI
CD pipelines deploy time policies and
runtime security posture
so while you're focused on writing code
software delivery Shield or SDS is
helping to make sure your organization's
security policy is consistently enforced
across the software delivery process
enabling you to develop faster in
addition to what we've covered we've
also been focused on helping remove
barriers across our data platform
allowing developers to build data-driven
applications faster
after all data often Powers the most
impactful experiences
we're providing integration with vertex
AI our AIML platform
this enables inferencing directly within
the database transaction
in addition we're announcing in preview
spanner integration with vertex AI
this integration allows data scientists
to build their models easily in vertex
AI and developers to access those models
using the SQL query language it's a
great time to be a developer because
software is enabling businesses to
reimagine how they're providing more
engaging experiences
in doing this with the peace of mind
that security is embedded at every step
of the way and everything I just
described was designed to help you focus
on what you love writing code fast
we're excited to create this future
together thanks for joining us